[Applaudissements]
quand je pense à la terre que je laisse
aux générations futures
je me sens heureuse me disait mon ami
l'ena chanceuse de vivre à notre époque
celle d'un môme ntoum où on a toutes les
cartes en main pour sauver le climat la
biodiversité et l'humain moi j'étais
encore un peu jeunes s'étaient pas que
c'était il ya quelques mois déjà et ce
que j'ai dit c'est j'ai honte plus que
coupable
j'ai honte d'avoir eu entre les mains la
plus belle baie bleue de tout l'univers
et de la voir casser le réchauffement
climatique c'est plus un degré
aujourd'hui plus de en 2040 + 5 à + 7 en
2005 ce que vous savez à combien
l'humanité est menacée +4 degrés alors
quand on entend ça on se dit à quoi bon
quoi puis qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
mais sortons delà les questions c'est
plus qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
qu'est ce qu'on va faire
qu'est ce que je vais faire pour changer
les choses
un changement radical est nécessaire
nous le savons aujourd'hui alors croyons
le et agissons en conséquence le
meilleur dans tout ça c'est que agir ça
nous fait du bien
alors je me présente je m'appelle
nicolas bourdeau je suis né à limoges
france terre je suis en deuxième année
dans cette école d'ingénieurs orienté
aérospatiale et je suis basculeur
j'ai 22 ans il ya encore je manger de la
viande
je connais l'avion je faisais même du
parachute j'avais une moto j'ai toujours
une moto tu pas encore réussi à m'en
séparer
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que en un
an on a le temps de beaucoup changé et
moi je me suis rendu compte de deux
choses 1
on est tous en détresse de ne pas savoir
de quoi le monde sera fait demain tous
mes deux l'existant une solution pour ça
agir avec nos moyens à notre échelle
agir c'est comprendre qu'on a de
l'emprise sur ce qui nous entoure et
c'est ça qui nous libère donc
aujourd'hui moi je voulais vous raconter
comment moi j'ai basculé dans l'action
alors on y va
il ya un nom j'arrive en école
d'ingénieur j'ai travaillé trois ans
pour ça et puis petit à petit je
m'informe de plus en plus je lis je
regarde des films je débats avec mes
amis ma famille et puis en parallèle je
m'investis de plus en plus dans le club
de supaéro for earth club écologique de
l'école sup aéro pour la terre jusqu'à
ce qu'un jour damien hillat tard
l'ancien président de ce club me dit
viens on va à paris il ya un week-end de
cohésion entre associations écologiques
étudiante de toute la france
ok ça redonne de l'énergie alors on y va
et le samedi matin bingo maxime de
rostolan nous propose une idée
et cette idée c'est la bascule basculer
c'est quitter une société productiviste
à la croissance alimentée par les
énergies fossiles pour travailler à la
suivante viable agréable parce que
quitte l'airé d'une sobriété heureuse et
la bascule c'est l'organisation qui vise
à amplifier les projets qui permettent
ça et à faciliter leur coopération
constat c'est que les solutions pour
changer la société elle existe ce qu'il
faut maintenant c'est leur donner juste
un peu plus d'énergie pour réussir à les
faire changer d'échelle et ce changement
d'échelle
il passe aussi par avoir du poids tous
ensemble et donc coopérer toujours plus
bon ok il faut de l'énergie mais on la
trouve ou bien l'idée qu'on a eu en
février 2019
c'était de réunir 100 personnes pour
travailler à la bascule à temps plein
pendant six mois
alors on y va on réalise une vidéo ont
fait une soirée de présentation et on
envoie des formulaires
on reçoit des centaines de réponses
l'énergie est là mais comment la
transformer en un pacte comment réussir
à faire en sorte de travailler
efficacement avec 100 personnes qui
peuvent venir des quatre coins de la
france alors pour répondre on fait un
petit saut dans le temps et on se
retrouve à pontivy en centre bretagne
dans une ancienne folie clinique
désaffectée depuis huit ans pourquoi
bien pour se réunir au même endroit pour
pouvoir travailler en physique ensemble
pour aller plus vite être plus efficaces
que s'ils ont travaillé à distance
alors pour ça à pontivy
on a créé ce qu'on appelle un quartier
de bascule un lieu où on peut vivre se
loger se nourrir gratuitement pour
pouvoir travailler à temps plein à la
bascule et ce qui est apparu en plus et
qu'on n'avait pas prévu c'est que ce
lieu vous le verrez un peu spartiate
il permet de se reconnecter à soi à ses
besoins profonds aux autres est la
nature
ce qu'on a fait c'est créer un mode de
vie où le vivre ensemble est au coeur de
toute chose
alors en parallèle de sa bien on a
réduit par quatre nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre soit l'objectif de la
france pour 2050 mais avec 30 en avance
[Musique]
alors je vais vous raconter notre façon
de fonctionner et puis un projet concret
sur lequel j'ai travaillé mais avant je
vous explique comment ça s'est passé en
pratique tout commence avec un chantier
participatif
trente personnes sont venues pendant
trois semaines tous les jours pour
déblayer les gravas lessive et des
pièces entières installé un petit peu
d'électricité et surtout apporter leur
joie de vivre et leur convivialité
aujourd'hui niveau infrastructure
toujours pas de chauffage de
l'électricité dans les salles communes
mais pas dans les chambres 50 watts de
panneaux solaires de douche chaude pour
60 personnes de frigo une machine à
laver et là je sais ce que vous vous
dites oui mais attend il attendait
combien de temps devant la douche le
gard
eh bien j'ai jamais attendu alors je
vous laisse réfléchir à ce petit miracle
et puis on passe à l'alimentation on
mange beaucoup de fruits et légumes
obtenu en échange de travail chez les
maraîchers du coin on a mangé plus d'une
tonne de pommes de terre parce qu'on a
fait un champ juste à côté de la
clinique
et puis sébastien un basculeur a appris
à faire du pain alors il nous en fait 10
kg par semaine
au niveau du transport c'est facile
travailler où l'on vit ça simplifie
grandement les choses et puis tout
pontivy est accessible en 15 minutes à
vélo ce vivre ensemble et ce qui m'a le
plus marqué ce que je garderai au plus
profond pour le meilleur et pour le pire
et ça c'est génial en plus parce que ça
simplifie grandement le travail ensemble
mais c'est pas suffisant pour réussir à
travailler ensemble d'égal à égal dans
une structure un petit peu plus
horizontale et bien il faut une posture
et puis des méthodes pour les apprendre
nous on a fait appel à l'université du
new les spécialistes du domaine de
l'intelligence collective qui nous ont
fait vivre une semaine de séminaire et
juste hallucinante quoi pour moi ces
gens sont clairement dans la catégorie
génie quoi c'est fou et grâce à eux la
bascule et en gouvernance partagée ce
que ça veut dire concrètement c'est que
on se répartit dans les groupes de
travail
selon nos appétence nos compétences des
groupes de travail comme outils
numériques ou soutien aux mobilisations
et puis on se donne beaucoup d'autonomie
et de responsabilité bon ok mais prendre
des décisions ensemble c'est jamais
facile
jamais prenons un exemple comment élire
le porte parole d'un groupe de dix
personnes qui soient réellement légitimé
par le groupe longtemps et bien la
bascule on utilise qu'on appelle une
élection sans candidat
personne ne se présente on défini
ensemble la fonction le mandat les
qualités nécessaires
on explique son vote quitte à le changer
ensuite et enfin on propose ensemble un
un des membres du groupe pour occuper le
rôle et ça ça change tout voilà doté de
ce mode de vie et puis toujours en
apprentissage de ces méthodes bien
s'élancer dans des projets et moi je
voulais vous parler d'un en particulier
jean of un événement de convergence
qu'on a organisé fin août à pontivy
alors en accueillant ses 250 personnes
représentants d'entreprises
d'associations politiques écrivains
réalisatrice on avait deux intentions
d'abord se connaître et puis travailler
ensemble parce qu'on travaille tellement
mieux ensemble quand on se connaît alors
la première journée était consacrée à
créer du lien en passant par différentes
phases la première s'ancrer dans la
gratitude envers ce qui existe envers la
beauté du monde
c'est se dire il n'est plus à prouver
que je suis personnellement un amoureux
des couchers de soleil j'aime les
abeilles bon la deuxième phase est moins
évidente
il s'agit d'honorer sa peine pour le
monde sait prendre en compte ce
sentiment quoi au lieu d'essayer
vainement de le taire inutile de mentir
lorsque ces abeilles meurent je souffre
la question
je construis à partir de ce à quoi bon
alors une fois qu'on a traversé sa
ensemble et bien on est plus apte à
s'ouvrir au regard de l'autre et à
construire des actions communes ensemble
par exemple le soutien à la rébellion
internationale d'octobre de la semaine
dernière à paris ou des bascules leur
ont facilité des débats avec des
centaines de personnes animer des
ateliers où était en soutien logistique
sur des tâches comme faire la nourriture
c'est lors d'un atelier du type de
l'anrf que mon ami l'ena me disais ce
trou est chanceuse de vivre aujourd'hui
peut-être que c'est elle qui a raison
peut-être at-on une bonne partie des
cartes en main aujourd'hui alors
utilisons les partageons ne ressentit
informons nous judicieusement mangeront
mieux et moins carnet chauffons nous
autrement
réfléchissons ensemble nos modes de
transport et chacune de nos
consommations matériel on peut faire
tout ça la question qui reste c'est
qu'est ce que moi je vais faire dans
tout ça merci
[Applaudissements]